ahora que ya sabemos un poco más sobre
oxidación y reducción
me gustaría que hagamos un ejercicio
para reconocer los estados de oxidación
de diferentes átomos en un compuesto por
ejemplo aquí tenemos óxido de magnesio
que se utiliza en el cemento y otras
aplicaciones y por acá tenemos hidróxido
de magnesio que se utiliza en antiácidos
y desodorantes los invito a que pause en
el vídeo y piensen en los estados de
oxidación si tienen estos dos compuestos
y con lo que ya sabemos sobre la tabla
periódica intenten descubrir los estados
de oxidación para los elementos en estas
moléculas
voy a suponer que ya lo intentaron pero
ahora hagámoslo juntos antes que nada
pensemos en el magnesio el magnesio se
encuentra justo aquí en el grupo 2 de la
tabla periódica es un metal alcalino
terreo tiene 2 electrones de valencia no
es muy electro negativo ya habíamos
visto que cualquier elemento de este
grupo tiene 2 electrones de valencia y
le gusta donar los para formar en la
sesión y cos o si es guionizado donará
sus 2 electrones cuando pierde 2
electrones entonces tenemos una carga 2
positiva el magnesio tiene un estado de
oxidación 2 más
y del otro lado de la tabla periódica el
oxígeno se encuentra en el grupo 6 tiene
6 electrones de valencia es muy electro
negativo es tan electro negativo que la
oxidación se llama así por él le gusta
quedarse con los electrones de otros
elementos particularmente le gusta
quedarse con dos electrones no es raro
ver que todos los elementos de este
grupo y especialmente el oxígeno toman
dos electrones de alguien más si tomamos
dos electrones y empezamos con un estado
neutral el oxígeno termina con un estado
de oxidación dos negativos
al parecer lo hemos resuelto el magnesio
puede tener un estado de oxidación 2
positivo y recuerden que como super
índice se acostumbre a escribir la carga
positiva después del número 2 y el
oxígeno tiene o puede tener un estado de
oxidación 2 negativo esto tiene sentido
porque la carga total de la molécula
debe ser neutral 2 más y 2 - es igual a
0 y en este caso el estado de oxidación
no es solamente una suposición de la
carga iónica porque en realidad este es
un compuesto único
el oxígeno realmente toma 2 electrones y
el magnesio realmente dona sus
electrones así que para este caso el
estado de oxidación describe lo que
únicamente está ocurriendo
ahora veamos la molécula que tenemos por
acá hidróxido de magnesio como vimos
anteriormente el magnesio tiene un
estado de oxidación en el que le gusta
donar sus electrones así que tiene un
estado de oxidación 2 positivo lo que
afecta a todo el año en hidróxido al
final toda la molécula debe ser neutral
pero para eso veamos solamente alan jon
hidróxido esta parte de la molécula el
hidróxido debe tener un estado de
oxidación dos negativos aquí tenemos dos
hidróxidos observen este subíndice que
nos indica que son dos moléculas y cada
hidróxido tiene una carga 1 - o 1
negativa
ese es el estado de oxidación total de
la molécula y si tenemos dos moléculas
entonces ya tiene sentido que la
molécula total sea neutral si el oxígeno
tiene un estado de oxidación 2 negativo
el hidrógeno tiene un estado de
oxidación 1 positivo cada hidróxido
tendrá un estado de oxidación 1 negativo
pero como tenemos dos el estado de
oxidación de esta parte de la molécula
es de 2 negativo y 2 positivos para el
magnesio tiene sentido